we are taking your phone calls at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let me pick up on our caller
from the 5 5 9 area code who's calling
today from 5 5 9 hi David this is John
hey John what's up hey so I was
wondering what do you think the
likelihood of the next president either
democratic or republican you know
wherever they may be with that they
would create some sort of federal
agencies oversee police investigations
into like police violence and misconduct
like that and what do you think the
effectiveness of such a agency could be
so I don't know if we need a federal
agency to oversee police I think it
would be really tough to get that done
with police unions being as strong as
they are in the next segment I am going
to give my prescription for dealing with
police violence and I'm going to talk
about databases of sorts I think that we
need two things and I won't fully go
into them because I'm going to do this
next segment number one there should be
a national database of bad actors in
police departments because right now it
is too easy I'm not saying it's easy but
it is too easy for a police officer to
make a deal to leave a department
because of wrongdoing or complaints but
it's done in a way where there's no
place that future police departments can
see this officers history and they end
up rehiring a problem officer and the
the vast majority of police officers are
not the problem the small percentage
that are often are repeat offenders so
by just eliminating a few of these bad
actors you would dramatically reduce the
number of bad acts so to speak so you
establish a database of police officer
complaints and you require both that a
police department has to report to the
database and a new hiring Police
Department must check the database so
that nobody can get away with saying we
just didn't know so that's one thing the
other thing is I think that we do need a
review system for police shootings and
use of force incidents that includes
civilians where in many cases these
things are reviewed essential
internally internally by police
sometimes in concert with you know the
DA's office in certain situations I
don't think that that's cutting it I
think we definitely need accountability
to civilians as well so those are a
couple of the things I think we need to
do I think a federal agency to do the
reviewing is going to be a tough sell
yeah I was thinking that the employee
like implicating such a system would
probably if anything just caused a lot
of backlash and you know attention to
the police union and yeah stuff like
that but I had one other quick question
yeah about Trump and his Twitter account
you know he's trying to push forward the
new restrictions on you know Ben
silencing conservative voices and
whatever making it easier to not get
blocked for you know to be conservative
or whatever right so is that in order to
help stop Twitter from blocking him the
day he's no longer president I don't
think that he's thinking ahead in that
way whatsoever I think that these are
basically politically partisan things
that Trump believes now will benefit his
side I don't think he's saying I'm gonna
do this so that Twitter doesn't block me
the day I'm out of I I just don't think
he's I honestly I don't I really don't
huh well maybe he's just incapable of
looking that far forward that that's one
of the reasons why alright thank you my
friend appreciate the phone call great
to hear from you